who is the cringiest person on the
planet ken
jayden smith oh
of course tyler the creator is my
[ __ ] boyfriend the man with ancient
wisdom the wisdom of a 3 000 year old
chinese warlord
with such famous quotes as how can
mirrors be real
if our eyes aren't real oh
jaden smith is back and he is uh still
cringe
thank god i need some i need some good
old jaden smith cringe in my life oh
yeah yeah
uh did you know that jaina smith is
under the opinion that if he were white
and not will smith's silly son i would
be the most respected philosopher of our
and old time oh all right
all the universes i love how he hit
silly with like four quotation marks too
just like no that's cool jaden with the
i appreciate your confidence but with
all due respect ain't nobody know who
the [ __ ] you are if you weren't will
smith that's true
come on ain't nothing wrong with that
too it's just like bruh shut up i love
how you're looking on the i'm 14 this is
deep too to find these
but he's the king of this subreddit it's
so good
yeah how diluted you have to be to think
being well smelly son is holding you
back
yeah
i have so much more everyone just thinks
of me as where's my son i go around
sometimes and i hang out with other
people that are my age and they're just
kind of
[Applause]
dude like oh my god like can we talk
about like the political and economic
state of the world right now
oh yeah everybody we're having a good
time with our tick tock and stuff and
he's like but
what about the politics
what about this inflation
i'm with you online
jaden i have a test for you
give it to me
so i'm going to read two quotes and you
guess which one is from jaden smith all
right kids who go to normal school are
so teenagery so angsty okay okay okay
and the other one is it's important to
love yourself because no one else does
geez
the first one is is jaden smith
correct and the second one by yours
truly that's right i am the most
respected philosopher of all oh my god
in my eye oh it was beautiful i wrote
this book with like ironic inspirational
quotes forever again are you reading
your own book right now everything looks
like right now this guy is hilarious
never give up on on those dreams of
yours and stuff nice okay
deep
how well did your book age do you look
back on it now and go oh yeah that's
good i i i wouldn't say like whoa but it
somewhere some are kind of funny i'm
trying to find a funny one though and
it's not growing outside
i remember when like you're like you
were starting all your book stuff and it
was like oh my god the book pewdiepie
book and i saw it in a bookstore and i
picked it up and flipped through it and
i was like
just saying don't say it okay
this is what everybody's talking about i
mean what is in here what do you mean
what would you this is
they how dare you i'm just i'm just
joking your book is like 10 times better
than like half the other youtuber books
are out there or most of you do other
youtuber books are out there impossible
is nothing
doing nothing is easy you could do
nothing nice that's my i love that one
that's my favorite one
don't sugarcoat everything you'll get
diabetes
great if you'll be asking jaden smith to
come over and play video games
oh snap it shayden hey jaden hey jayden
you want to come over and uh to my house
and we can play on the ps2 and my mom
can make us cookies we're gonna have
some get your dirty peasant hands off of
me
you want me to come to your house and
play playstation and eat junk food
why would i waste my time with silly
activities when i could be studying
politics
worrying about the economic
status of the world
come with me boy
jaden we're nine years old what's going
on with me young one i may look nine
externally but within
i'm merely 100 years old
what the hell are you on i come on
jesus christ because
you're born alone
and you die alone and this world just
drops a bunch of rules on you to make
you forget but me
i never forget
we're not
[Laughter]
i miss just playing playstation 2 oh
simpler times
simpler times jaden smith can't relate
though
he came to this planet the human brain
takes in 11 million bits of information
every second but is aware only of 40.
what huh did you human brain takes in
how many
informations per second i love that to
get like a whole like studio like blow
some fog in here and just film me
looking confused bro
okay
i appreciate some level of
self-awareness but it's clearly also
just like when it comes out but guys
let's talk about politics guys yeah you
see your nose all the time
your brain just chooses to ignore it
it's right there
don't forget
oh [ __ ]
that one that one got me not gonna lie i
get it now he is the greatest
philosopher did i scare you
my nose did you play a horror game
that's not a jump scare so it's just
like jaden smith it's popping up on the
screen
on saturn and jupiter
it rains diamonds how
human salivary contains a painkiller
called opioid that is six times more
powerful than morphine hold that back up
on the
saliva
what was it called
ah
felix i got shot you gotta spit on me
i guess it's like technically the same
chemical compound or something but it's
not activated in this because it needs
something
else a natural painkiller found in human
spit a new painkilling substance that
proved that been discovered
when was it 2006 that's old news ain't
real anymore too old oh so it's better
if you kiss don't spit bro i'm dying oh
bro i got you
bro what are you doing i'm doing i gotta
do bro i gotta save you bro
i mean no homo
thank you jaden smith for this
50 of human dna is shared with a banana
unbelievable
oh yeah why am i not a banana huh
explain that well i mean there may be a
part of your body similar to banana you
know
that part of my body is uh
there are more ways to shuffle a deck of
cards
than there are atoms on earth
if you drilled a hole through the center
of the earth and jumped in it
you don't end up in china did you know
that is that what it's going to say
because that pisses me off it would take
42 minutes to reach the other i don't
give a [ __ ] all right
if you drill
a hole
do you end up in china all holes through
the world end up in china okay it's just
how it is you would you would end up in
the southern hemisphere nowhere near
china
this is bowling
oh my no no it's like there's like a
portal in there man if you if you go to
china and drill a hole straight down
you'll come back out in china anyway
it's how it is there's like a blue
portal down there and there's like an
orange portal above china where do you
have to be to dig to china
argentina only argentinians can dig to
china this is [ __ ] dumb i gotta
google if in swedish in new zealand
oh oh you'd be right next door to me
nice
just jump down bro like boy bro
be right there bro boy bro welcome new
zealand bro is that idxp you got to go
out there and clean their dick they're
what if you're like me you find it very
hard to keep your dick dry i left my
dick unprotected and it was whooped out
of shape in no time i could barely
recognize my own dick imagine yeah
that's
i actually did that too and it it
corrects it you definitely want to
protect your game yeah you got you got
to you got it yeah yeah
i don't know how i got this house and
they didn't pretend i discovered
schaefer's new zealand style deck
sealant the best way to take care of
your
easy steps first wash your dick with
soap and water then wait for your dick
to dry
once your dick is clean and dry paint
your hair this is easier humor i love i
used to be too embarrassed to invite
people over to see my dick that's a nice
looking dick yeah
i even have pictures on my deck check
out that deck
this is my secretary
barbara always loves to receive my dick
pics
oh he made the joke
all right back to jaden smith
yeah gotta blow my mind here total
amount of hours that world of warcraft
players have played the game
it comes out to over six million years
i definitely contribute to that one yeah
so that's really fun
that is really funny that's really funny
what do you have to say about that when
the oldest living person was born they
had an entire different set of people on
the earth with them
no one was the same
that's deep you know what kind of blows
my mind a little bit what everyone is
doing something right now
everyone's living their own individual
lives with their own families and their
own problems what do you think brad
pitt's doing right now like he's doing
something probably i don't know how he's
taking a massive
that's what i've been doing if i was
brad pitt you know what blows my mind
uh-huh is it probably you know when
we're older and like you know
our kids have kids and their kids have
kids no one will remember us okay well
what about this thing you just look back
on 10 years ago you can hardly recognize
like where you were and what you were
doing it's like you were a completely
different person
god you mean i grew up as a person oh
it's more like you've already lived the
life and it's already my god are you
saying there's hope for people to get
cancelled to grow and
change
okay that's not all right oh sorry
i would never go that far
strawberries aren't berries but bananas
are and so are watermelons and avocados
wow
i don't care i don't they're not berries
you cannot just systematically organize
things okay i organize them by their
shape and size like we do with
everything okay you can't just be like
technically it has to i don't care it
has a speed
yeah yeah i don't give a [ __ ] it's like
the people that said pluto wasn't a
planet i'm like bro no it's a planet you
[ __ ] it
you can't walk back on this they did
they did walk back
no i don't care it's a planet i don't
give a [ __ ]
are we done
okay great
then he fades away
if a bookstore never so he actually
tweeted look
does that mean that nobody reads it
or everybody reads it
i also love how people like you
misspelled something you got to zoom in
on that oh my god look at he misspelled
unbelievable i have never done that in
my entire life i'm gonna talk about how
like every freaking word is capitalized
and there's no punctuation at the end
we're not talking about that we're just
talking about the note
whenever i see something misspelled i'm
like i look at the keyboard oh no the
people look at the keyboard i'm like is
there a letter next to that oh yeah okay
so that's just a normal mistake yeah
yeah it's not that difficult like who
cares we're defending jaden smith we're
on his page now he's my hero
damn
what's gonna happen jayden
oh my god when i die did you realize
like some authors aren't famous until
like 30 years after they die or
something they're like this guy's pretty
good we'll go back and be like that's
luke
you know everybody pray
yes we were so silly for making fun of
it how could we have been so blind we
should have talked about the politics
and the economy
yes because that always fixes everything
right
people that say politics are so
important are always like solving all
these problems right now yeah that's
great well we could all be a little bit
more like jaden smith yeah i guess
you're right what's that in front of you
ken
it's your nose